Hello everyone. How are you doing? This
is Jin with next level commander and
today we have a deck that builds towards
an end game that is perpetual. That it
just doesn't run out of gas. And somehow
it's Selesnya. Now I think in my 15
years of playing commander, I've never
built a Selesnya deck. It really is the
most boring color combination. I don't
think this is a hot take. Now recently
there's been a few kind of interesting
ones, but not interesting enough for me
to actually build and try them. Now that
is until the mystery boosters. They made
Elda is both powerful and really fun to
play. Not sure about your opponents
though cuz playing against this deck
will feel like hitting a pillow while
being stuck in quicksand. Yeah, that
sums it up. And as always we are
building our core game plan around Elda.
Now people do rightly point out that I
do sometimes spend way too many card
slots dedicated to the core game plan
and not leaving enough room for the
creative stuff, you know, battlecruisers
and even pet cards. So today this deck
is different. The core engine is just
six creature cards and four tutors to
search for them. And that's it. For the
rest of the deck you can play pretty
much whatever creature package you want
and it will work. And the core engine is
Whitemane Lion and friends. How the lion
works is when it enters it bounces
something. It can also bounce itself
back to your hand. And that means with
Elda it can constantly recycle another
creature and itself while leaving a
token behind. Unfortunately, Whitemane
Lion is actually unique in what it does
in all of magic. Fortunately though, it
is pretty difficult to kill especially
when combined with all these backup
plans. Now these include the Rescuer
Chwinga, Ambrosia Whiteheart, Sun Pearl
Kirin, and Jeskai Barricade. Now these
ones unfortunately only bounce another
permanent or creature, so they can't
recycle themselves. That's the biggest
weakness. So they have to be used in
conjunction with each other. With Elda
out and two of these in hand, we can
cast a Sun Pearl Kirin, demonstrate it.
The token enters first which will
recycle something for us and then the
original Kirin enters which will bounce
either the token or a recycle another
creature. And now if we have say Jeskai
Barricade and Hand, we can have these
two cards constantly recycle each other
and at the same time reuse a lot of our
ETB effects. And also, just to add one
more to the list, Stonecloaker. This is
a Whitemane Lion with some extra perks,
but the one extra cost can be pretty
expensive. It's much better with cost
reducers, though. So, yeah, this is the
squad. With this setup, we can
constantly bounce. They can protect each
other. They can protect Elda. And also,
they trigger cast, ETB, and all kinds of
other abilities. And this is what we're
building around. And because Elda's
ability says each turn, I decided to go
with creatures that have flash. And the
choices are slightly limited, but we do
get to cover up most of the utilities.
We are a bit thin in some areas, but we
do get to reuse our cards, so it's not
the worst. For removals, we do have the
War Fox Bodyguard, Angel of Dire Hour,
and Solitude. Now, with these, I have to
be careful because when I demonstrate
them, they can easily be used against
us. So, you're going to need some table
talk, and if that doesn't work out, you
might just not want to demonstrate.
There are a few cards that can bypass
this, though, like
Now, this, when you demonstrate it, it's
just six damage to every flyer. It
clears the board of dragons and pesky
angels, mostly. So, that's a pretty good
choice. And also, Green Slime and Aven
Interrupter. Now, you don't gain too
much on the spot for demonstrating them,
but there is some synergy with tokens
and stuff. Now, I guess it's to be
expected, but a lot of the flash
creatures are protection or blink
creatures, which is fine. Like, we don't
really care what they do that much. We
just want to do something on every turn
to be able to use the demonstrate
ability for other synergies. Then, they
can protect our core pieces and also
reuse any ETB effect. So, why not? We've
got these and also a few legendary ones.
Now, these can't be demonstrated, keep
in mind, but they're still excellent
utility to be using over and over again,
so they're in. And aside from protecting
permanence, green and white are also
excellent at protecting ourselves from
combat, mostly. He is Frog, Selfless
Squire are excellent. Set's Tiger is
very versatile. My favorite one, though,
is Windshaper Planetar. You attack who I
want you to, and yeah, reusing this over
and over again is just brutal. Combine
that with Sigarda's Vanguard, and you
are dominating combat. And once again,
the creature suite is pretty flexible.
You can choose whatever flash creature.
You can go a bit more staxy if you want,
but I chose not to because I don't want
to stacks myself when I demonstrate, and
I do want to demonstrate for maximum
value. All right, so And you can also
even play just regular ETB creatures,
but make sure you have plenty of flash
enablers. That's one way to do it.
Again, it's very flexible as long as you
have the core. Another reason I chose to
go with smaller flash creatures is that
there is also a sweet package of
enablers that can get us so much value
from these small creatures. Well, for
example, Karametra. Karametra with
Whitemane Lion is just a classic
combination. Another great card is
Earthcraft. With this on the field, all
your Whitemane Lions and any creature,
really, they will reimburse you one mana
on the spot, or even two if that's the
one you chose to demonstrate. And also,
we get to use a bunch of card draw
engines, like the ones that trigger when
you cast, or the ones that trigger when
you when tokens enter, when creatures
enter. Yeah, these are all excellent.
Tishana, which is Miku now, I I guess.
Everything is Miku now. And this is like
a perfect card for this deck. You get to
gain so much life, and the populate has
excellent synergy with our commander.
And God Eternal Oketra. This is a pretty
resilient win condition, and yeah, this
can amass a board state very quickly,
and you can swarm your opponents. Oh,
and also Suture Priest. Now, this one,
I'm not sure if it's impactful enough,
but it's super cute in this deck. You
can demonstrate it, give a copy to, say,
opponent A, and now every creature you
demonstrate, you give to opponent B,
which will drain them for three life
each. This can add up pretty quickly if
you have like two or three creatures
being demonstrated per turn. And also,
you know, they might play their own
creatures. And if you really want to
hate on this one person, you can bounce
Suture Priest, demonstrate it again, and
you will have five seven copies on the
board. Yeah, that's pretty funny. And
there are a few other enablers that are
like made for this deck. The first one
is the new Radagast. Yeah, this ability
is just chef's kiss. It is perfect. And
here we also get to play Aluren. And
this one is might combo pretty easily.
Yeah, but again, this is really the
perfect deck for that. And finally, a
game changer in Seedborn Muse. Because
yeah, enter the battlefield decks, even
if it's Selesnya, even if it's with a
twist, it's pretty powerful and can be
annoying to play against depending on
your opponent. So, I'm not sure about
including this in bracket two. And yeah,
Seedborn Muse is the ideal game changer
for this deck. So, yeah, bracket three
is I think where we should be aiming
for. For the other game changer, I chose
Aura Shards because yeah, just imagine.
So, these are the two I have for now.
And last but not least, Silverquill
Lecturer. This is basically our
commander, but without any restriction.
With this on the field, our deck shifts
into another gear, but is at its best
when we have enough mana, when we have
enough resources. So, don't just drop
this early if you have this in your
opening hand, just drop the commander
and save this for later. And that's the
enablers. We have a few tutors like I
mentioned before, mostly for White Main
Lion and friends, but once you have the
lion, you can tutor for anything. These
are pretty flexible. The one that's
interesting here is Defense of the Heart
because your commander can essentially
feed your opponent's creatures. So, it's
very difficult for your opponents to
stop the trigger. So, now I think you
know what I mean when I say this deck
does not run out of gas. The White Main
Lions, the bounce creatures will
constantly recycle our cards. We can
play the same four or five cards for the
entire game and just win with those. And
all of our key creatures and commanders
are protected by these bounce effects.
When we have this kind of value engine,
the only bottleneck is mana. So, I
dedicated 19 slots to ramp in this deck.
Now, most of them I chose creatures
because they synergize with our
commander, but I think it might be
correct to actually go down to the two
mana ramp options. I think what I'm
doing is a bit greedy. So, if you try
the deck, find it to be too slow, cut
these Farhaven Elves for Nature's Lore.
And a few non-creature options are these
cost reducers. Yeah, these are brilliant
for what we're trying to do. And that's
it for lands. Since we are casting
multiple spells a turn, we do need very
good color fixing, leaning a bit heavier
towards white. But as long as you keep
your color fixing on point, uh you can
play your favorite utility land. There's
no
crazy synergy here, except for maybe
a Dark Depths. A Dark Depths? Kind of
Yeah, I can make copies of it, and then
I can populate it. But yeah, I can find
Oh, yeah. We do want Reliquary Tower
because we can just hoard a massive
hand.
Yeah, and we can like we just this
entire hand's going to be recycled and
reused.
So, that sounds pretty fun, you know,
having 15 cards in hand and being able
to use any of them at any time. Now,
this deck does take a little bit to get
started, but you do have a lot of ETB
creatures in your hand, so you can just
deploy them early. Even without
Demonstrate, they can do decent work.
And once you have Elda out, your deck
turns into a different beast. And this
is
probably one of the most resilient decks
I've ever built. Yeah, like I mentioned
earlier, once you have your engine set
up, have a decent number of lands,
you're not going to run out of things to
do. The deck is pretty difficult to
play. I tried it. There's a lot of
sequencing. There's a massive decision
tree sometimes. And playing at instant
speed, while powerful, means that you
have to pay attention all the time.
Every time you get priority, there's
potentially something to do. Also, these
tutors, they require you to kind of know
the deck, especially these X cost ones.
You don't want to mess that up. Make
sure to be very careful with your
commander. Don't just drop it on turn
four. If it gets removed, then
yeah, your deck will be slowed down by a
lot. Play with just your regular
creatures, stall the game, and
once you have six mana and one bounce
creature in hand, now this is where you
can deploy Elda.
And the moment you untap with this, you
enter Value Town. Now, again, I built a
full budget version, but I I think this
can be done at a lower budget. A lot of
these expensive cards are really nice to
have, but they're not really core to our
game plan, except maybe I think Seedborn
Muse will be nice to have. But
everything else is just a fun luxury
edition that you don't really need to
have. The lion is the core of the deck.
Okay, and that's all for the deck. Now,
time for giveaway information. First of
all, we once again have a giveaway for
this video for the beautiful Kakapopo.
Now, these I've been using long before I
was sponsored, before I even had a
YouTube channel, actually, and they've
been quality. And we'll be giving away
two of these, one to a random comment,
and another randomly selected among
comments that suggest cards that end up
being chosen for the deck. Cuz we're
trying to make these lists as tight as
possible, and yeah, for the for the
Nephilim video, for example, those
suggestions were amazing. I ended up
swapping out like 10 cards, but yeah,
let's do the same for this video. And
now, I'm announcing giveaway winners for
the Homer video. We have Spades.
Nice. And also, Plump.
I hate you. But yeah, congratulations.
Please contact me on Discord, and that's
all we have today for the video. And but
please stay tuned and subscribe because
these mystery commanders are amazing. I
keep See, I keep discovering more that I
want to build. I can't even move on to
other sets anymore.
But yeah,
these are sweet. I will see you in my
next video.